unless you've been living under a rock you've
probably tried asian skincare products already
skincare culture is a bit different in
asia so there are lots of awesome asian
products that we don't really get in western
countries plus they're usually budget-friendly
today i'm going to be reviewing some
really awesome asian beauty products
i've tried recently as well as
some that were pretty bad a lot
of these are products that viewers have
recommended to me they're some of those
cult asian products that you've heard a lot
about online yes it is mostly sunscreens
there are five in there but there's also
some cleansing products as well as makeup
this video is sponsored by stylevana which
is where i got all of these they have a
massive range of asian beauty products they've
also given us a discount code to use as well
we're starting with the canmake mermaid skin
gel uv this is an spf 50 plus pa ++++ sunscreen
it was a holy grail sunscreen of mine but then
they reformulated or repackaged i'm not entirely
sure so it looks like the old version which i
really loved became the clear version and the
whitening one that one purposely makes your skin
a little bit whiter which is quite popular in asia
this sunscreen is really beautifully
light on the skin it's also unscented
and it's not really siliconey i have this
problem where when i use sunscreens with a
lot of silicones they often become quite oily
throughout the day on my skin it also doesn't
have alcohol i know alcohol is a problem for a lot
of people it's not really an issue for me but if
that's what you're looking for this is great it
works really well under makeup and there's zero
white cast on my skin at least it's also fine
around my eyes there's none of that eye stinging
now the filters in this there's octinoxate uvinul
a plus zinc oxide titanium dioxide and tinosorb s
i reviewed the old version and this is the same so
this is back up to holy grail
status i highly recommend it
our next sunscreen is the nivea uv super
water gel 50. this is spf 50 and pa +++ so
it's a little bit lower in protection than the
canmake sunscreen this is a super lightweight
sunscreen and it has this effect where when you
put it on your skin it feels like it bursts into
water so it feels super refreshing after you've
applied it it is very lightweight but you can
still feel it a little bit on your skin this
is the 80 gram bottle if you buy the slightly
larger version it comes in a convenient pump the
filters are octinoxate dhhb and octyl triazone
it does have a pretty strong alcohol smell
when you put it on at first my main issue
with it is the slightly lower protection but
as an everyday sunscreen it is really nice
now onto two of the more confusing sunscreens i've
tried lately the isntree sunscreens these are both
from the hyaluronic acid range and as you can tell
they look pretty much the same and that's where
the confusion came in they're both spf 50 plus
and pa ++++ i saw julian @scamander14 who does
a lot of sunscreen reviews on instagram he has
really dark skin and he was using one of these
and it looked fantastic on his skin so i was
really excited to try this of course i grabbed
the wrong one which is the perfect sunblock the
packaging is really not friendly for those of us
who are usually in a rush and not super observant
the perfect sunblock pilled massively on my skin
and i was actually rushing off to a picnic
with one of my friends who has brown skin
and i was going to give him a sunscreen and i
packed this one of course and then i noticed
it turning white on my skin so then i had to
pull that out of the bag he didn't turn up to
the picnic anyway so i guess it was fine i did
end up using it on my arms which i forgot to
put sunscreen on before the picnic so luckily
i had this and it is quite nice on the arms
it uses titanium dioxide which is why it
has this massively whitening effect some
people have asked me if a titanium dioxide only
sunscreen can actually have this pa ++++ claim
in other words can it actually be broad spectrum
and give good uva protection the answer is yes a
lot of older books and papers say that titanium
dioxide can't give good uva protection but there
are newer titanium dioxide ingredients out there
now that tick off the criteria for broad spectrum
on their own so they give a good spread of uva and
uvb protection titanium dioxide is a particulate
mineral sunscreen ingredient which means it is in
lots of little solid particles with these solid
particulate sunscreen ingredients there are lots
of things that you can change like the particle
size and the surface treatments that will change
how that ingredient performs when it goes under uv
so in other words what uv wavelengths it will
absorb more so for example croda which is a
cosmetic ingredient company they give an example
formulation that uses their own titanium dioxide
ingredients and it ends up with spf 65 and uvapf
26 which would translate to the same rating as
this i don't know the exact titanium dioxide
ingredient that this sunscreen is using of
course but that rating is possible with just
titanium dioxide but anyway the white cast
and the pilling disqualified this for me and
overall it was just a very rude experience
but it turns out the one that i was meant to get
was the watery sun gel and this one is a really
nice sunscreen it uses a whole bunch of organic
sunscreen ingredients so octisalate homosalate
bemt mbbt polysilicone-15 and dhhb it's
pretty nice and light and hydrating it's
not as ridiculously light as the nivea
or the biore but it is really good for
oily skin it could probably stand to
be a little bit more hydrating though
sunscreen number five is the thank you
farmer sun project light sun essence
this is an spf 50 plus but
only pa with three pluses
this applies with a similar sort of silky
feeling as the can make sunscreen but it is
a bit heavier it has a whole bunch of chemical
sunscreen ingredients dhhb octinoxate octisalate
homosalate and octocrylene the fact it's a bit
heavier and the lower uva rating means that this
can't make it into my holy grails but i think it
is quite a nice everyday sunscreen if you have
maybe drier skin and you want something a little
bit heavier that can double up as moisturizer
now on to the cleansing products this is the
unique calendula complete cleansing oil this
is a fragrance free cleansing oil which usually
i'm a little bit hesitant about but it smells
like a cooking oil and i can't actually smell
any rancidity in this that's that slightly sour
smell that you sometimes smell in oils usually
with cooking oils when you've had them open for
too long i have only had this for a few months
but i also can't find any reviews that have ever
mentioned it so it's quite possible that it stays
non-rancid for quite a while a lot of cleansing
oils have noticeable rancidity after a few months
and that's because a lot of oils will oxidize with
oxygen and light if the oils in a cleansing oil
aren't selected carefully especially if they're
using plant oils and especially if there's no
masking fragrance then this rancidity can be a
bit of an issue and it's much more obvious because
this is the sort of product that you would put
really close to your nose so this is actually a
really nicely done fragrance free cleansing oil
i would still prefer something that
didn't smell so much like cooking oil but
if you can't handle fragrance and you prefer
plant oils in your cleansing oils then this
is a really nice option you can also pick ones
which have more stable oil so you would avoid
any plant oils that have lots of linoleic acid
for example maybe stick to things like mineral
oil jojoba oil and squalane this is pretty good
at getting rid of makeup and it rinses off pretty
cleanly and it comes in my favorite packaging
for cleansing oil which is a pump bottle really
convenient the only thing is i do like a little
bit of a subtle fragrance in my cleansing products
and that's the same problem i have with the
hada labo gokujyun hydrating face wash this
is a cleanser that comes with a foaming top and
it is fragrance free which is a selling point
for a lot of people but it's just not really up my
alley this is a really nice cleanser it's not very
hydrating it's not very stripping either and it is
pretty much just fine in every way but it's just a
little bit joyless i didn't realize this would be
such an issue for me but it just kind of felt like
a chore to use it feels a bit like the skincare
version of soylent nutritionally it's exactly what
you need with nothing extra but kind of feels
a bit flavourless i definitely prefer it over
a product that's really nice to use but strips my
skin massively but i would just prefer something
a little bit more exciting but for those of
you who just want a really solid cleanser that
works well and has no frills then this would be a
fantastic pick it just isn't really my cup of tea
now on to the makeup this is the hera
sensual spicy nude balm in naked almond
that is a lot of innuendo for a lipstick this
is actually the lipstick i am currently wearing
i guess we don't really talk about asian makeup
a lot because makeup is something that it's a
lot easier to try in person so this was a bit of
a blind buy but i'm really glad i got it it is a
really pretty brick red color it looks a lot like
my favorite lipstick which is toast of new york
by revlon but it's a sheerer color and it looks
more like a gloss there is a little bit of a minty
feeling on my lips not a ton and the fragrance
is really nice it smells like a cup of tea i
also really prefer this sort of stick format which
is a little bit harder to find with asian brands
most asian brands that i've looked at have those
doe foot gloss like applicators and while they're
okay they're not my preferred way of applying
lipstick i prefer a much more oily product
i think maybe i'm just not quite coordinated
enough to deal with a doe foot on a daily basis
i also tried some gel eyeliners from the brand
merzy these gel eyeliners stay on really well and
they didn't transfer at all even though my eyelids
are super oily this one is a normal sized one and
this one is a slim eyeliner both of these don't
blend that well once you've put them on your skin
you do have to work quite quickly and so if you're
using your finger just like apply it smudge it
apply the next part smudge it again i am wearing
it on my eyelids at the moment and you can see
i haven't really bothered blending it much
because it is actually quite difficult the
regular eyeliner comes with a sharpener in the end
that you can pull out now the slim one is really
cool it is only 1.5 millimeters in diameter which
means it's really thin it's really easy to control
and you can draw a really good cat eye with it
really easily it does tend to break off really
easily because it is so slim so the merzy website
does give a tip where you only wind up so there's
about a millimeter sticking up before you start
using it the problem is because it is so skinny
there isn't that much product inside this like
the cylinder total mass is just tiny it is 0.05
grams which is 50 milligrams versus in the big
one you have 10 times as much of that solid black
product 0.5 grams and even that isn't very much
product compared to my usual revlon colorstay
creme gel which is 1.2 grams so it's a bit more
than twice as much as in the big one and it is
24 times as much as in the slim one so while the
slim one is a really cool product and i haven't
really seen anything like that on the market
before it is something to keep in mind it is
probably not going to be the product that you use
to draw a really thick eyeliner line on every day
so all of those are from stylevana they've
given me a discount code which is right here
if you've tried any of these products
before let me know what you thought of them
please consider subscribing if you've learned
something new also click the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any uploads and i
will see you next time to nerd out more